i heard something like from a few
different places just very recently that
i just absolutely loved and i couldn't
believe that i didn't like it didn't
occur to me sooner but the idea that
that money doesn't change people it
simply amplifies
the way that they already are
um interesting this is something that i
first heard khabib
this is the fighter khabib nurmagomedov
he said it about conor mcgregor you know
like a lot of people want to give conor
mcgregor a pass because he just came in
to like hundreds of millions of dollars
and it's going to make you he said it
could be something
like whatever you are money makes you
more of that and
what do you agree with that i do i do
and i've since heard that in uh in
multiple other contexts
that i can't uh you know well i think
that's true like in the in the short
time that i've known you like you have
money and you're sending people to get
help in colombia like that's what you
decide to do with your money you know
and
um
but then that goes to the question of
like who are we are we like are we evil
are we villains and um are we good
people are we here you know
i guess
part of that is
um
let me let me try
like like if i close my eyes right and i
go
holy [__]
i never need to move again i never need
to move again right like i'm talking
about a contraption that like i can hire
enough people
for the rest of my life
where i i just don't have to do anything
i didn't have to walk to this van i
could have someone like carry me here
like annabelle so if i think like that
then it's like holy [__] you know
um and then
like you don't know this this life until
you have it right so people are like oh
man you hang out with all these rich
people it's like look there's these isms
right more money more problems with with
uh money is power with great power comes
great responsibility like these things
are all true for a reason you know and i
i could be like well i didn't want this
i didn't want this responsibility
and you know in that case i kind of
sound like spider-man like i didn't want
this it's like well you have it now
right so you have a responsibility that
you didn't want and now you got to do
something with it and so that's what i'm
doing that's
i i don't really
like talk about it that much um
like one of the things uh you know
five seven years ago was when i was like
the most out of my [__] mind you know
and
and um part of getting better is
is service work right and and like i'm
like i'm not like i don't [__] need
to lift a finger i'm not help you know
like oh you want me to help someone
here's a check and they're like
that's easy to write a check for you
like you gotta do you gotta like
put your effort and action you know
so
i'm like super into animals i'm super
into like dolphin therapy horse therapy
and like the first time i did horse
there have you done it you point there
god knows all about it my my sponsor is
like the guy
for equine therapy on the east coast and
west coast so all right so like
the first time i did horse therapy i
don't know how to ride a horse so i'm
like oh cool i'm gonna ride a horse and
they're like oh no you don't even touch
the horse and i was like what what the
[__] and they're like
um horse therapy is like
or the one i the ones i did was like how
do you get horse from a point a to point
b without touching it so then you see
all the addicts go get over there or
like trying to bribe him with the apple
and it's like it's just like when you
calm down the horse mirrors you right so
when you calm down the horse comes down
so
and then it follows you so i'm
i'm like all right cool like that's i
want to do something with that so i was
living in arizona a few years ago and
i volunteered at this ranch who does
equine therapy with um at-risk youth uh
like kids with um autism and just
special needs and addicts and i'm like
dude i'm gonna become like this horse
and they go um we don't need any
we need tons of volunteers but we have
enough of those people we need people to
shovel [__]
and in my mind because you know i'm like
dude i'm [__] dave joe like you know
how much you like i'll [__] hire a
team of people to shovel you know
that's my ego flaring up right i'm like
i'm not [__] shoving [__] and then my
sponsor at the time is like bro we're
shoveling [__] that's what you're doing
and my ego is just like out of control
it's like i am 100
how is this gonna help me get better
it's like you don't know what you don't
know till you try it right
so i shoveled [__] for almost a year
i went there every day complaining like
you know and i went under there for like
a different name because i didn't want
anyone to like google me and you know
and i'm just like watching kids and like
in my mind i'm like i love [__]
teaching kids i love like helping people
like i want to do that [__] over there
and they're like yes so there's more
manure here and you know and and you
know that kind of [__] when you do you
smell like it all day even if you shower
right so i'm smelling like [__]
but during during break time
like i'm doodling like and so one day
the the lady that owns the whole ranch
is like um hey johnny
hey johnny i you you're like really good
at drawing and i was like oh thanks
and and she goes you know we're having
um
you know we're having a special event
this weekend for like victims of abuse
like do you want to do you want to come
and draw portraits of them and i was
like yeah sure like and then once again
the ego is like
[__] do you know do you know how
much i charge for this [__]
and i go
yes i'll yes i'll do that you know
so i get there that weekend it's like a
special day and it's like all these
services for like you know these people
that have been abused
it's like free hair free manicure like
free clothes like all these people
setting up and so i sit down with like
my little easel
and it was all
sexually trafficked you know
the victims of like ex-prostitutes ex
you know
and um you know
i had been with
i don't know how many prostitutes in my
life you know all over the world
and
i just i i just froze up
had to take a [__] kind of just hit in
the bathroom and i was like i should
just go home like i just felt
i just felt shame i was just like man
i've i've been a part of this and this
is not
this
i can't i can't heavy i can't be here
you know and as i start to walk out the
door
uh the lady's like hey johnny you know
first the first woman you know she's
ready and she's like
so uncomfortable because she's like no
one's ever
i've only been looked at as like a
sexual
being i've just been used by men and i'm
like oh [__] dude
so i sit there and i start drawing her
and i'm like
i gotta [__] like
i gotta make this like the best drawing
i've ever done in my life
um so
so i'm like and i'm a little rusty
because i've been doing the shoveling
[__] you know
so i'm like drawing her and i'm trying
to make her as beautiful and i'm like
and i'm i'm like really seeing her and
then she starts crying because she's
like i've never had anyone draw my
portrait in like
jesus so
she goes and she goes takes it to all
the other women there and she's like
this guy over there just drew that so
then the line starts forming
and i'm like holy [__] like this is
crazy and there was like 50 women there
that day and all of them have like the
most heartbreaking you know
the worst stories ever
and you know i i the event started at
noon or something and there they were
only going to go till five and i stayed
till midnight and i drew all of them and
like everyone went home and i was still
there
and um
it just like broke me you know just like
destroyed me and
um there's a part of my ego that's like
hey guys you know i'm famous you could
sell this thing and
you know but it was just
it was so
raw and so personal and
and i go
anyone could write a check which i do
that also right and i tend to do that
anonymously i don't like being hey the
dave cho part of this you know i just do
that but i'm like
i'm i have a skill i can give back like
i can help people so like i that's
that's where i that's that's how i spend
my time i stopped selling my art in 2009
so that's all i do now i do murals i do
anything where my art can be seen or
received for free online murals
posters whatever i just give away or
doing murals with kids or people that
have been like you know that's that's my
work and
um when you did the drawings of all
these 50 women you say it broke you
but
the way that you told that story it was
so beautiful
it
seems to me that that would have been on
some level healing oh i mean
it it broke me and it and it healed me
you know it just like i i think i just
like cried the entire drive home that
day and then
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]